We'll do it in Haskell first. Why not? Because we're a Haskell podcast, aren't we? Uh, sure. Secretly. So the blood cake is a cream cake. Alright, back to Rust. So the whole point of this... No, no, no. You can't tell men. It was a mallard duck. The ones that don't have the shiny green heads are the moms. I didn't have my glasses on, so it was a blob.
我们先用 Haskell 实现。为什么不呢？因为我们是一个 Haskell 播客，不是吗？呃，当然。私底下是。所以布莱德蛋糕其实是奶油蛋糕。好了，言归正传，继续聊 Rust。所以这整件事的关键…… 不，不，不。你不能告诉男人们。那是一只绿头鸭。那些没有闪亮绿头的是妈妈。我当时没戴眼镜，所以它对我来说就是一个模糊的团块。
Are we going back to Rust? Alrighty. Let's get back to Rust. They know that I would never do anything to stress out or offend some waterfowl. To get back to why Rust is so amazing. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 142, recorded on June 18th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we record live on the road from Slovenia during our Slovenia 2023 road trip. In this episode, we review Bled Lake, Bled Cake, and solve one problem in Haskell, Rust, and C++, and talk about why Rust is so awesome. We are back, and we are finally in Slovenia.
我们这是要回到 Rust 了吗？好吧。让我们回到 Rust 吧。他们知道我绝不会做任何让水鸟感到压力或冒犯的事。回到 Rust 为什么这么厉害。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 142 期，录制于 2023 年 6 月 18 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天与我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，在我们 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行期间，在斯洛文尼亚的路上进行现场录音。在本期节目中，我们回顾了布莱德湖、布莱德蛋糕，并用 Haskell、Rust 和 C++ 解决了一个问题，还探讨了 Rust 为什么如此棒。我们回来了，而且我们终于到达斯洛文尼亚了。
Listen, folks. Bryce is not bringing the adequate amount of enthusiasm to the Slovenia 2023 road trip. Depending on how the podcast got edited, this might be in the middle of a podcast where Bryce got lost because a cycling race messed up our directions. So bring it back here. Bring it back here. Or this might be the start of episode two or episode three. We don't know. But guess what, folks? The last two episodes or one and a half episodes were live from Austria. Now we are in Slovenia.
听着，各位。布莱斯对 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行的热情明显不够。根据播客剪辑的情况，这可能是在某个播客的中间，当时布莱斯因为一场自行车赛把我们的路线搞乱而迷路了。所以把它拉回来。把它拉回来。或者这可能是第二集或第三集的开头。我们不知道。但你猜怎么着，各位？过去的两集或一集半都是从奥地利现场直播的。现在我们在斯洛文尼亚。
It's beautiful. Guess what? We're the number eight. Last time we checked. Technology podcast in Slovenia. We're here. We made promises and we delivered. We just got finished at Bled Lake.
这里真美。你猜怎么着？我们排名第八。上次我们查看时。这是斯洛文尼亚的技术播客。我们来了。我们许下了承诺，并且做到了。我们刚刚逛完布莱德湖。
We had some Bled cake. Apparently, we're taking a right-hand turn. I'm pretty sure we're taking a right-hand turn. I'm pretty sure we're taking a... I don't think we're taking a right-hand turn. It says we're going left in five or six minutes. Nope. You have made a tactical mistake. Don't listen to that because that's going to take you...
我们吃了一些布莱德蛋糕。显然，我们要右转了。我很确定我们要右转。我很确定我们要……我觉得我们不会右转。它说我们将在五六分钟后向左转。不对。你犯了一个战术错误。不要听那个，因为那会带你去……
No. Yeah. I can't tell how bad the mistake is that you just made, but we just went from an ETA of one hour to one... Holy shit, I added 23 minutes? Hang on. Dude. Get off here.
不。是的。我看不出你刚刚犯的错误有多严重，但我们的预计到达时间（ETA）刚刚从一小时变成了一……操，我增加了 23 分钟？等一下。老兄。从这儿下去。
Dude, you're so fired. It was set... Did it not say go left 500? Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, no, no. I agree it was unclear. Oh, 500? Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, no, no. I agree it was unclear. Oh, look. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So it just wants us to go back.
老兄，你被炒了。它设置的是……它刚才没说左转 500 吗？对，对，对。不，不，不。我承认这很不清楚。哦，500？对，对，对。不，不，不。我承认这很不清楚。哦，看。对，对，对。所以它只是想让我们回去。
So it's only out in six minutes. Sure, yeah. It's supposed to 30. Anyways, folks. How do we get out of here, though? I don't know. You figure that out. It's a truck stop.
所以只要六分钟就出去了。当然，是的。应该是 30。总之，各位。不过我们怎么离开这儿？我不知道。你自己想办法。这是一个卡车休息站。
It can't be that hard. So apparently it's very hard to find a grocery store on Sundays in Austria. And also they told us in Austria that we had to get this little sticker thing to go into Slovenia. And that they told us every gas station will have a little sticker. Well, Connor, did every gas station have a little sticker? No, but we only went to one gas station. No, we went to two gas stations. They both told me no sticker. Is that true?
不可能那么难。所以很显然，在奥地利星期天找一家杂货店非常难。而且他们在奥地利告诉我们，我们需要买一个小贴纸才能进入斯洛文尼亚。并且他们告诉我们每个加油站都会有小贴纸。那么，康纳，每个加油站都有小贴纸吗？没有，但我们只去了一个加油站。不，我们去了两个加油站。他们都告诉我没有贴纸。是真的吗？
Yes, they both told me no sticker. We went to the Shell and what was the other one? The other one earlier. Oh, the Turmoil. Yeah, the Turmoil. Yeah, that's right. Get it? Turmoil.
是的，他们都告诉我没有贴纸。我们去了壳牌（Shell），另一个是什么？另一个是早些时候那个。哦，托莫伊尔（Turmoil）。对，托莫伊尔。没错。懂了吗？托莫伊尔（混乱）。
We love you, Austria oh man we the the the drive the part of the drive where we cross from from austria to slovenia you're you're driving in between like in this this pass between these two mountains and man that was some of the most gorgeous uh driving that i've ever been a part of it was quite beautiful i mean i've also done yosemite i've also done switzerland but it's up there it was it definitely felt like we were in a mazda commercial there were 270 degree angle turns it you know it was i think more intensive than yosemite and that's like i think prior to this, the, the, the sort of wildest drive I've ever done, you know, and we were talking about this a little bit earlier. I got to wonder like, what's it like to be the guy who designed or the guy or girl, the entity,
我们爱你，奥地利。哦天哪，我们……开车的那段路，就是我们从奥地利穿行到斯洛文尼亚的那部分，你是在两座大山之间的山口中驾驶，天哪，那真是我经历过的最美丽的驾驶体验之一。真的非常美。我的意思是，我也去过优胜美地，我也去过瑞士，但它绝对名列前茅。那感觉真的就像我们在拍马自达的广告，有 270 度的急转弯，你知道的，我觉得它比优胜美地还要紧张刺激，我想在此之前，那是我经历过的最疯狂的驾驶体验，你知道的，我们刚才稍微讨论过这个。我在想，设计道路的人，或者那个男人、女人、实体，
an entity who designs roads. What's it like to be a road engineer like like you you you come to this mountain pass and you're looking at it and like what what like expertise were you taught where you're like you know what right here we're gonna do like a 270 degree turn and then another 270 degree turn and then another one and then like we're gonna do like this weird thing here like how do you like let's look at the mountain and be like yeah that's that's what we should do that's exactly how this should work it was a little uh uh you wanted to nope nope you have made a mistake again oh you're man do not give me the mic dude you bryce telling me i made a mistake almost got me to drive straight into oncoming traffic.
设计道路的实体是什么感觉？成为一名道路工程师是什么感觉？当你来到这个山口并看着它时，你被教导了什么专业知识，让你觉得，你知道吗，就在这里，我们要来个 270 度的转弯，然后再来个 270 度转弯，接着再来一个，然后像这样在这里搞个奇怪的东西？你究竟怎么能看着大山然后说，是的，这正是我们应该做的，这正是它应该运作的方式？这有点……呃……你想去——不，不。你又犯了一个错误。哦，老兄，别把麦克风给我，老兄。布莱斯告诉我我犯了错误，差点让我直接把车开进迎面驶来的车流中。
This guy, he's like, don't worry, I won't make you drive the whole thing. There is no way we're letting you get behind the wheel, man. I'm definitely. You were like going the wrong way. Okay. Maybe. You almost made me go straight into oncoming traffic. Maybe you are correct.
这家伙，他就像是，别担心，我不会让你开全程的。我们绝不可能让你坐在方向盘后面，老兄。我绝对。你刚才开反方向了。好吧。也许吧。你差点让我直接开进逆行车流中。也许你是对的。
Jeez Louise. Romana yells at me about this too. I tell ya. All right. traffic maybe you're correct jeez louise formana yells at me about this i tell you all right so um so we drove through this mountain pass and it was beautiful and then we got to the uh the lovely town city of bled and uh what did we do in bled we don't i dove multiple times into the water we swam a couple little baby ducklings, a couple ducks. It was actually just a mom duck. We don't know what happened to dad.
老天爷。罗马娜（Romana）也为此对我大喊大叫。我跟你说。好吧。车流，也许你是对的，老天爷，罗马娜为此对我大喊大叫，我跟你说。好吧，所以……所以我们驱车穿过了这个山口，景色美极了，然后我们到达了……布莱德这个可爱的小镇/城市，我们在布莱德做了什么？我们……我好几次潜入水中，我们游了一会儿，看了一些小鸭子，还有几只大鸭子。其实只有一只鸭妈妈。我们不知道鸭爸爸怎么了。
It looked like it was a solo mom duck. Maybe it was dad and no mom. No, no, no. You can't tell men. It was a mallard duck. The ones that don't have the shiny green heads are the moms. I didn't have my glasses on, so it was a blob to me. How do you not?
看起来只有一只孤单的鸭妈妈。也许只有鸭爸爸没有鸭妈妈。不，不，不。你不能告诉男人们。那是一只绿头鸭。那些没有闪亮绿头的是妈妈。我当时没戴眼镜，所以对我来说它就是一个模糊的团块。你怎么会不知道？
Man, you do not need glasses to be able to tell a female duck from a male duck. And that was definitely Mom with her two baby ducklings. And Bryce got a little bit too close a couple times, was upsetting the baby ducks and Mom duck. Excuse me. I was keeping a respectful distance. It was Connor who wanted to go over to them
老兄，你根本不需要眼镜就能分辨出雌鸭和雄鸭。那绝对是带着两只小鸭子的鸭妈妈。布莱斯有好几次靠得太近了，惹恼了小鸭子和鸭妈妈。不好意思。我一直保持着尊重的距离。是康纳首先想靠近它们，
in the first place and was bothering those ducks. I was not bothering any ducks. We love the ducks. Look, my followers know that I love waterfowl. They know that I would never do anything to stress out or offend some waterfowl. I know how to say, Ja lubię kaczka,
并打扰了那些鸭子。我才没有打扰任何鸭子呢。我们爱鸭子。听着，我的粉丝们都知道我热爱水鸟。他们知道我绝不会做任何让水鸟感到压力或冒犯的事。我知道怎么说“Ja lubię kaczka”，
which means I like ducks in Polish. We're not in Poland, but I don't know how to speak Slovenian, so that'll have to do. Slovenian listeners, I apologize for Connor. Look at this nice little river here. Oh man, look at these mountains.
这在波兰语里是“我喜欢鸭子”的意思。我们不在波兰，但我不会说斯洛文尼亚语，所以只能这样了。斯洛文尼亚的听众们，我为康纳向你们道歉。看这美丽的小河。哦天哪，看看这些山。
I gotta say, look, our Austrian listeners, we love you dearly. You have a beautiful country. We had a great time in Vienna. However. However. We're in Slovenia, baby, and it's way better.
我得说，听着，我们的奥地利听众们，我们深深地爱着你们。你们有一个美丽的国家。我们在维也纳玩得很开心。然而。然而。我们在斯洛文尼亚了，宝贝，这里好得多。
It's true. That once we got through the pass, once we came out of the tunnel, the border is in a tunnel, and once we came out of that tunnel into the Slovenia side, it was a lot better. Let's do a, uh, let's do a live review of the after we swam with the ducks in the beautiful electric blue blood lake. Highly recommend. We then went and had, we almost forgot we were supposed to have the blood cake and we're looking for gelato and ice cream. And then I was like, wait a second. I saw some guy eating what looked
真的。一旦我们穿过了山口，一旦我们走出了隧道——边界就在一条隧道里——一旦我们走出隧道来到斯洛文尼亚这一侧，情况就好多了。让我们来做个……呃，在我们和美丽的电蓝色布莱德湖中的鸭子一起游泳之后，来个现场评价。强烈推荐。然后我们去吃了……我们差点忘了我们本该吃布莱德蛋糕，当时我们正在找意式冰淇淋（gelato）和冰淇淋。然后我就想，等一下。我看到有人在吃看起来像
like blood cake. And I was like, we forgot we went and had it. What's your review, Bryce? Well, so the blood cake is a cream cake. The base is sort of like a light, fluffy, some sort of custard something. It's definitely got agonist. I'll tell you that. And then there's a layer on top of it of, I think it's probably whipped cream. And then on top of it is like a flaky, a layer of like flaky pastry crust. Yeah, yeah.
布莱德蛋糕的东西。我就想：我们差点忘了，我们去吃了。你的评价是什么，布莱斯？嗯，所以布莱德蛋糕是一种奶油蛋糕。底部有点像那种轻盈、松软的某种蛋奶冻（custard）。里面绝对有某种……我只能这么说。然后在它的上面有一层，我想可能是鲜奶油。再上面是一层酥皮，一层酥脆的糕点皮。对，对。
Like pie crust. I don't know if it was like pie crust. It's more like, it's a lot flakier than pie crust. All right. I think. And then a little bit of powdered sugar on top. So first of all, let's break this review down into a few pieces. So first, let's talk structurally.
就像派皮一样。我不知道它是不是像派皮。它更像……它比派皮酥脆得多。好吧。我想是的。然后在上面撒了一点糖粉。所以首先，让我们把这个评价拆解成几个部分。首先，我们来谈谈结构。
So the bottom two layers, they're a little jiggly and don't really have shape. And then on the top, you've got this, like, pie crust layer that you kind of got to cut through. And that was a little challenging. Wow, look at those mountains there. Wow. Damn. Wow. Wow, look at those mountains there. Wow. Damn. Wow. We'll take pictures for you, dear listener. What Bryce is trying to say is that dessert lacked structural integrity. Yeah, but in terms of taste, it was not a heavy dessert. I'll say that. It was a little sweet.
所以下面两层有点晃晃悠悠的，并没有真正的形状。然后在顶部，你有这样一层像派皮一样的结构，你得切过去。这有点挑战性。哇，看看那些山。哇。靠。哇。哇，看看那些山。哇。靠。哇。亲爱的听众，我们会为你拍照的。布莱斯想说的是，那个甜点缺乏结构完整性。对，但在味道方面，它不是一个厚重的甜点。我得这么说。它有点甜。
I didn't find it too sweet. But, you know, I'm not a good judge of that. Bottom layer was, it was good. It wasn't maybe my favorite flavoring. But, you know, it was light and sort of refreshing. So I would maybe give it a 6 or a 7 out of 10. What do you think? Why are we doing this out of 10?
我觉得它不是太甜。但是，你知道，我不是这方面的行家。底层是……它挺好的。可能不是我最喜欢的口味。但是，你知道，它很轻盈，而且有点清爽。所以我可能会给它打 6 分或 7 分（满分 10 分）。你觉得呢？我们为什么非要用 10 分制？
It's out of 5. 3.5 or 3 out of 5? I would give it a 3.7, 3.8 maybe. All right. You heard it here from Bryce. 3.7 or 3.8 out of 5 connor's review 5 out of 5 yeah you might be thinking why is this a 5 out of 5 well that's because upon looking at this bled cake this cream cake if you will i thought to myself one thing and one thing only there's no way in hell i'm gonna like this because i don't don't typically like, you know, I hate custards.
满分是 5 分。3.5 分还是 3 分（满分 5 分）？我可能会给 3.7、3.8 分吧。好吧。你们从布莱斯这里听到了。3.7 或 3.8 分（满分 5 分）。康纳的评价：5 分满分。是的，你可能会想，为什么这是 5 分满分呢？好吧，那是因为一看到这个布莱德蛋糕，这个奶油蛋糕（如果你这么叫它的话），我脑子里就只有一个想法：我绝对、绝对不会喜欢这东西，因为我通常不喜欢……你知道的，我讨厌蛋奶冻。
You discarded a whole donut earlier. That's true. Just because of that crack. I had to get my Austrian donut because we were only in Austria for like 24 hours. And so I bought one. It looked like a sugar donut. It turned out it was a vanilla donut, which is like a sugar donut. But it was a donut with a hole in it sugar donut but it had it was not it was a
你之前扔掉了一整个甜甜圈。那是真的。就因为那个裂口。我不得不买我的奥地利甜甜圈，因为我们在奥地利只呆了大概 24 小时。所以我买了一个。它看起来像个糖甜甜圈。结果发现是个香草甜甜圈，就像糖甜甜圈一样。但它是一个带洞的甜甜圈。糖甜甜圈，但它有……它不是……
it was a donut with a hole in it yet somehow they put cream inside the donut and i don't like cream in my donuts i was just about to say now you listener might be thinking what is connor talking about you know he clearly you know if a donut's got filling inside because if it has no hole in it no hole but this donut it looked like a regular donut it had a hole i was surprised to learn there was cream in it yeah but anyways back to the blood cake yeah so uh back to the blood cake so anyways i don't like i don't like multiple textures especially jellies inside of things i hate custards if you are in a country like america or canada and you know what costco is you know that they have these Costco cakes.
它是一个带洞的甜甜圈，然而不知怎么的，他们把奶油塞进了甜甜圈里面，而我讨厌甜甜圈里有奶油。我正要说呢，现在你这个听众可能会想，康纳在说些什么呢？你知道的，他很清楚……如果一个甜甜圈里面有馅，因为如果它没有洞的话……没有洞。但这个甜甜圈，它看起来像个普通的甜甜圈，它有洞。我很惊讶地发现里面有奶油。对，但不管怎样，回到布莱德蛋糕。对，所以……回到布莱德蛋糕。所以不管怎样，我不喜欢……我不喜欢多种质地，特别是里面的果冻类的东西。我讨厌蛋奶冻。如果你身处像美国或加拿大这样的国家，而且你知道好市多（Costco）是什么，你就知道他们有这种好市多蛋糕。
And I'm sure this is in other countries in the world. And instead of having like icing on the outside and icing in the middle, it's icing on the outside and custard in the middle. I hate custard in the middle of my cakes. And so I took one look at this blood cake, and it looked like custard on the bottom, some kind of whipped cream in the middle, and then this flaky thing. And I thought to myself, the only thing I'm going to like about this is the flaky thing. And it turns out it was fantastic. The custardy thing didn't taste like custard at all, at least not the cheap stuff that you get in the Costco cakes. It was light. It was lovely. The whipping cream like thing, also super light. Didn't really taste like much. So like it's five out of five
我确信世界上其他国家也有这种蛋糕。它们外面不是糖霜，中间也不是糖霜，而是外面是糖霜，中间是蛋奶冻。我讨厌蛋糕中间有蛋奶冻。所以我看了一眼这个布莱德蛋糕，它看起来底部是蛋奶冻，中间是某种鲜奶油，然后上面是这个酥脆的东西。我当时想，我唯一会喜欢这东西的地方就是那个酥脆的部分。结果证明它棒极了。那个蛋奶冻的部分一点也不像蛋奶冻，至少不像好市多蛋糕里那种廉价的货色。它很轻盈。很美味。那个类似鲜奶油的东西也超级轻盈。其实没什么太重的味道。所以它能得 5 分满分，
because I liked it, folks. Not because it is as good as anything I've ever tasted. I was just, it was delightful. Bryce finished his in about a fifth of the time that it took me to finish mine. But overall, five out of five. Would recommend even if you're thinking, you know, this doesn't look like it's for me. Surprise yourself, folks. You got to always be willing to try things. Put yourself outside of your comfort zone. That's what I'm all about here on ADSP, the podcast. I'm all about taking this podcast on the road and putting myself outside my comfort zone.
因为我喜欢它，各位。并不是因为它像我尝过的任何东西一样好。我只是觉得……它太令人高兴了。布莱斯吃完他的蛋糕所用的时间大约是我吃完的五分之一。但总体而言，5 分满分。强烈推荐，即使你心里在想，“这看起来不适合我”。给自己一个惊喜，各位。你必须总是愿意尝试新事物。让自己走出舒适区。这就是我在 ADSP 播客中所倡导的。我致力于带着这个播客上路，并让自己走出舒适区。
Boom. All right, what are we talking about now? Are we going back to Rust? All righty, let's get back to Rust. All right, so we were... Mike. I have all the power now. Yeah, but you're just providing a bad audio experience for our listeners
砰。好了，我们现在在聊什么？我们要回到 Rust 了吗？好吧，让我们回到 Rust 吧。所以我们刚才……麦克风。我现在拥有全部权力。对，但如果不把麦克风对准正在说话的人，
if you don't put the mic when the person's talking. So Rust, we were talking about Rust earlier. We were doing a live version of Mastermind. Should we resume that? No, I do not. I think that we do not need to torture the listeners with me failing to crack a code. But depending on how this gets edited,
你只是在给我们的听众提供糟糕的音频体验。所以关于 Rust，我们刚才在聊 Rust。我们当时在做一个真人版的“猜数字”（Mastermind）游戏。我们应该继续吗？不，我不想。我觉得我们不需要用我破解密码失败来折磨听众。但根据这个视频是如何剪辑的，
I kind of messed up because initially I actually described the problem as using the digits. Oh, man. Look at that. Wow. Damn. Damn. It damn damn the rockies folks these are some beautiful mountains and uh and i think we're heading up into them uh we should say i do not think we're driving up there that around them we should say the way, our entire itinerary for this trip was gifted to us by our good friend Gaspar, who is from Slovenia. And we asked him for some recommendations. And,
我有点搞砸了，因为最初我实际上把问题描述为使用数字。哦，天哪。看那儿。哇。靠。靠。靠，靠，落基山脉的各位，这些真是美丽的山脉啊，呃，我想我们正朝它们开去……我们应该说，我不觉得我们是开上山去，而是绕着它们开，我们应该这么说。有一点是，我们这次旅行的整个行程都是由我们的好朋友加斯帕（Gaspar）送给我们的，他是斯洛文尼亚人。我们向他征求了一些建议。而且，
you know, if he'd sent back, you know, oh, go to maybe check out this restaurant and do this or that, you know, we would have, that would have been enough. I would have, you know, we would have checked it out. Maybe we would have done some of the things. But that's not what he provided us. No, he gave us a detailed plan. Itinerary. Itinerary for what we should do. And, you know, when somebody gives me that, my gut is just to be like, you know what?
你知道的，如果他回信说，“哦，去看看这家餐厅，做这个或那个”，你知道的，那就足够了。我会……你知道的，我们会去看看。也许我们会做其中的一些事情。但那不是他提供给我们的。不，他给我们提供了一个详细的计划。行程。关于我们应该做什么的行程。而且，你知道，当有人给你这个时，我的直觉就是：你知道吗？
We're just going to go with that. And so that's what we're going with. And thus far, it is not disappointed. Not disappointed at all. It's been fantastic. Gasper, we love you. Thank you. We love Slovenia.
我们就按那个来。所以这就是我们正在做的。到目前为止，它并没有让人失望。一点也没有失望。棒极了。加斯帕，我们爱你。谢谢你。我们爱斯洛文尼亚。
We love the Slovenians. And for those of you that don't know Gasper, he's a member of the C++ committee. And so C++ developer. Does he work at Citadel with? He does work at Citadel, yeah. I wasn't going to say because Barry works at Jump. But anyways, Gaspar Asman, we'll put his Twitter
我们爱斯洛文尼亚人。对于那些不认识加斯帕的人，他是 C++ 委员会的成员。所以他是个 C++ 开发者。他在 Citadel（城堡投资）工作吗？他确实在 Citadel 工作，是的。我本不想说，因为巴里（Barry）在 Jump 工作。不管怎样，加斯帕·阿斯曼（Gaspar Asman），我们会把他的推特
in the show notes. If you want to go give him a follow on Twitter, show him some love for the love that he's shown us by giving us a little itinerary to tour through his country. It's been great so far. Yeah. And back to Russ. Enough about C++. So we don't need to resume that Mastermind
放在节目简介里。如果你想去推特上关注他，向他表达爱意，感谢他为我们提供穿行他国家的行程而对我们展现的爱。到目前为止真的很棒。是的。回到 Rust。关于 C++ 就说这么多。所以我们不需要恢复那个“猜数字”
game. This might be the same episode, might be a different episode. What a reprieve for me. Yeah. That I don't have to embarrass myself. If you've been waiting for like a week or two, though, to know if you guessed the code correctly, the code was the first Ramanujan number, 1729, which technically violates the initial rules that I set because Mastermind has eight colors, and I said we'll use the numbers one to eight,
游戏了。这可能是同一集，也可能是不同的一集。对我和说是个多大的解脱啊。是的。我不用出丑了。不过，如果你已经等了一周或两周，想知道自己是否猜对了密码，密码是第一个拉马努金数（Ramanujan number），即 1729，这严格来说违反了我最初设定的规则，因为“猜数字”游戏有八种颜色，而我说过我们要使用 1 到 8 的数字，
and nine is not in that range. And then at one point you asked, is zero a valid digit? And I said yes, and I realized we were now playing ten-color Mastermind, not eight-color. It's all right, though. The point is,
而 9 不在这个范围内。然后在某个时候你问，零是有效的数字吗？我说是的，然后我意识到我们现在玩的是十种颜色的“猜数字”，而不是八种颜色的。不过没关系。关键是，
you got the gist of how that game works, and ooh, look, some motorcycles passing us. I gotta say, lovely country, lovely people thus far minus all the people on the motorcycles as a former actuary uh i just want to let all the folks know you should not drive motorcycles if you are concerned about mortality risk that is for those that are not informed of the actuarial terms the the risk of dying, which typically most people are not. They're pretty not interested in dying.
你掌握了那个游戏的玩法，哦，看，有些摩托车从我们旁边开过去。我得说，美丽的国家，可爱的人们，除了所有骑摩托车的人。作为前精算师，呃，我只想让所有人知道，如果你担心死亡风险，你就不应该骑摩托车。对于那些不了解精算术语的人来说，死亡风险，通常大多数人并不怎么关心。他们其实很不愿意见阎王。
And if you are interested, you are 80 times. That's 8-0 multiplicatively. We're not talking 80%. We're talking that's like 800, no, 8,000, 8,000%, a.k.a. 80 times more likely to die on a motorcycle than you are inside a vehicle. Also very likely to die inside a vehicle. But my point is, it's not very safe. I understand why people are doing it, though, because it's very beautiful to zip through these mountains, the views.
如果你有兴趣的话，你的概率是 80 倍。那是 8-0 倍的乘数。我们说的不是 80%。我们说的是大概 800……不，8000，8000%，也就是在摩托车上丧生的几率是在汽车内的 80 倍。在汽车里面也很容易死。但我的重点是，这很不安全。不过我理解为什么人们要这样做，因为穿梭于这些山脉之间感觉非常美妙，风景极佳。
Anyways, back to Rust. So 1729, the first Ramonajan number. We love it it even though we violated the problems but you should get the gist of when bryce would guess and he got exact matches the right number in the right place or the right color in the right place that is a function that was shown in a talk called point for your die which i borrowed and then basically replicated and solved in both uh haskell and i believe bN, or maybe it was APL, in my composition intuition talk. So you can think about this function. You're given two strings. In the classic example,
不管怎样，回到 Rust。所以 1729，第一个拉马努金数。我们很喜欢它，尽管我们违反了题目要求，但你应该能领会到当布莱斯猜测时，他得到了完全匹配（数字正确且位置正确，或者颜色正确且位置正确），这是一个在一个名为“为你的骰子打分”（point for your die）的演讲中展示的函数，我借用了它，然后基本上在我的“组合直觉”（composition intuition）演讲中，在 Haskell 和我相信是 BQN，或者可能是 APL 中复制并解决了它。所以你可以考虑这个函数。给你两个字符串。在经典的例子中，
it's like letters that represent the colors. So like blue, blue, green, green would be BBGG. That would be the code. And then your guess might be blue yellow green red so b y g r so you got two strings bbgg and bygr and you need to return a single integer value given these two sequences these two strings that returns the number of characters that match exactly in this string so you're not you're not worried about the ones that aren't exact matches. This is just a function that returns you the number of red pins that you would have done. So in Haskell,
它就像代表颜色的字母。比如蓝色、蓝色、绿色、绿色就是 BBGG。这将是密码。然后你的猜测可能是蓝色、黄色、绿色、红色，所以是 BYGR。所以你有两个字符串 BBGG 和 BYGR，你需要根据这两个序列、这两个字符串返回一个单一的整数值，它返回的是在这个字符串中完全匹配的字符数。所以你不用担心那些不完全匹配的。这只是一个函数，它返回你会得到的红针（red pins）的数量。所以在 Haskell 中，
we'll do it in Haskell first. Why not? Because we're a Haskell podcast, aren't we? Sure. Secretly. Haskell. Give me the mic back. I'm not sure if we should. I'm not sure if we should. I'm not sure if we should subject our users to Haskell.
我们先用 Haskell 实现。为什么不呢？因为我们是一个 Haskell 播客，不是吗？当然。私底下是。Haskell。把麦克风还给我。我不确定我们是否应该。我不确定我们是否应该。我不确定我们是否应该让我们的听众遭受 Haskell 的折磨。
So Haskell, this is a... Well, actually, how about you? What would you do to solve this? We'll do it in C++ first, and then we'll do it in Haskell. How would you do this? So it's a function that takes two strings. They're length four, but you could arbitrarily solve this for any length strings or, you know, sequences or ranges.
所以 Haskell，这是一个……好吧，实际上，你呢？你会怎么解决这个问题？我们先用 C++ 实现，然后用 Haskell 实现。你会怎么做？所以这是一个接受两个字符串的函数。它们的长度是 4，但你可以任意解决任何长度的字符串或（你知道的）序列或范围。
And you want to check how many are equal and return that number back. So for BBGG and BYGR, you're going to turn back two because the first B matches and the first G matches. Nothing else matches. But this is just checking whether they match,
并且你想检查有多少个是相等的，然后把这个数字返回。对于 BBGG 和 BYGR，你会返回 2，因为第一个 B 匹配了，第一个 G 匹配了。没有其他的匹配了。但这只是检查它们是否匹配，
but not necessarily whether they match in place. No, it's making sure that they match exactly in the right positions. Hang on. I think we just made a tactical mistake. Oh, yes. Wasn't looking at the directions. We are now four minutes slower, but it's all right.
但不一定是检查它们的位置是否匹配。不，它确保它们在正确的位置上完全匹配。等一下。我觉得我们刚刚犯了一个战术错误。哦，是的。刚才没看路线。我们现在慢了四分钟，不过没关系。
We're going to do a little U-turn at the next round. All right. So this function, okay, so just go. This one is just checking whether these match. It's not whether they're in the right place. Correct. So an alternative example is if you don't want to use characters
我们将在下一个路口做个小掉头。好吧。所以这个函数，好的，那就走吧。这个只是检查它们是否匹配。不是看它们是不是在正确的位置。正确。所以一个替代的例子是，如果你不想用字符，
because that's too confusing, if you have the sequence 1, 2, 3, 4, and 4, 4, 4, 4, your answer is? You're supposed to guess what the answer is. The answer is 1. Because you've only got one number that matches the sequence.
因为那太混乱了，如果你有序列 1、2、3、4 和 4、4、4、4，你的答案是？你应该猜猜答案是什么。答案是 1。因为你只有一个数字与序列匹配。
If you're given the sequence 1, 2, 3, 4, and 2, 2, 4, 4, your answer is sorry one two because all right but if it's like two two four four and four four four four um two exactly yeah so you're basically just doing an element wise comparison and counting how many of these oh exactly. Okay, I guess that's... You've given away what you want to do there, which is I guess you just I mean, you could just do like a
如果你得到序列 1、2、3、4 和 2、2、4、4，你的答案是……抱歉，是两个，因为……好吧，但如果是像 2、2、4、4 和 4、4、4、4，呃，正好是两个，对。所以你基本上只是在做一个逐元素的比较，数一数有多少个……哦，完全正确。好吧，我想那是……你已经泄露了你想在那里做的事情，我想你只需要……
Play along, listener. Play along, listener. I mean you could just do like a uh play along listener play along listener think about it first let's zip them and then um uh and then we'll do a a reduce with
跟着做，听众朋友。跟着做，听众朋友。我的意思是，你可以像这样……跟着做，听众朋友，跟着做，听众朋友。先考虑一下，让我们把它们 zip（拉链）起来，然后……呃，然后我们做一个 reduce 带着……
uh no I guess I'm to need like a transform reduce. Um, yeah, I guess it can just be like a binary transform reduce, right? This is the binary transform reduce where your, um, where your transform just compares whether or not they're equal and returns 1 if they are and 0 otherwise. And then your reduction operator just sums. That is absolutely correct, Bryce. Except for the fact that in C++ we have... Huh? Two words.
不，我想我需要一个 transform reduce。嗯，我想它就像一个二元 transform reduce，对吧？这就是那个二元的 transform reduce，其中你的……其中你的 transform 只是比较它们是否相等，如果相等返回 1，否则返回 0。然后你的 reduction 运算符进行求和。完全正确，布莱斯。除了这样一个事实：在 C++ 中我们有……哈？两个词。
One starts with an I, and one starts with a C. Implicit conversions. And therefore... I mean, you can... Yeah, sure. You can just use a comparison as your first function. It doesn't need to be a custom written function. It can just be equals and reduce your first function. It doesn't need to be a custom written function.
一个以 I 开头，一个以 C 开头。隐式转换。因此……我的意思是，你可以……是的，当然。你完全可以把比较作为你的第一个函数。它不需要是一个自定义编写的函数。它只需是 equals，然后 reduce 你的第一个函数。它不需要是一个自定义编写的函数。
It can just be equals, equals and reduce. Exactly. Not equals, though. Equals is an algorithm. Stood equal to is your binary operation. Sure, equal to, yes. Ooh, a little waterfall here. Ooh, that's nice.
它只需是 equals、equals 然后 reduce。没错。不过不是 not equals。Equals 是一个算法。std::equal_to 是你的二元操作。当然，equal_to，是的。哦，这儿有个小瀑布。哦，那真不错。
Yeah. But that is, it's beautiful. You can solve this in a single line, transform, reduce. Your first binary operation That's going to do the zipping is equal to stood colon colon equal to your second binary Binary operation is stood colon colon plus and you're done. That's it So it's a transform reduce or an inner product and C++ in Haskell You don't have a single algorithm for this so you're going to do a zip with
是的。但那真的很美。你可以用一行代码解决这个问题，transform reduce。你的第一个二元操作，将要做 zipping 的是 std::equal_to，你的第二个二元操作是 std::plus，这就完成了。就是这样。所以它是一个 transform reduce 或 C++ 中的 inner product。在 Haskell 中，
which is the equivalent of our zip transform and C++23 with range adapters, and you're going to provide it the equal equal in order to do an equality comparison, and that's going to return you back trues and falses. You can then either map from enum. I just don't want to hit these bikers here. You can map from enum, which will turn your booleans into integers because Haskell does not have implicit conversions. It's also not hit the car. Yeah, that's good. Oh, there's another waterfall. Wow.
你没有针对这个的单一算法，所以你要用 zipWith，
Beautiful. And then you just do a sum after that. So why did we go through all this, you know, solving it in Haskell, solving it in C++? It's because three hours ago, or whenever the last time we were recording back in Austria, we were talking about Rust and why it's so awesome and how the
这相当于我们在 C++23 中结合范围适配器（range adapters）的 zip transform，你要提供 equal 来进行相等性比较，那会返回给你 true 和 false。然后你可以从 enum 映射。我只是不想撞到这里的骑车人。你可以从 enum 进行映射，这会把你的布尔值变成整数，因为 Haskell 没有隐式转换。顺便别撞到车。是的，很好。哦，又是一个瀑布。哇。
tool chain and the ecosystem and the experience. Wow, look at this lake. It's so beautiful. It's a pretty nice lake, yeah. This entire series of podcasts is just going to be... Talk, talk, talk, talk, wow! Talk, talk, talk, talk, wow!
真美。然后在此之后你只需要做一个 sum。所以我们为什么要经历这一切，你知道的，在 Haskell 中解决它，在 C++ 中解决它？这是因为三个小时前，或者我们上次在奥地利录音的时候，我们一直在谈论 Rust 为什么那么棒，以及工具链、生态系统和体验。哇，看看这个湖。太美了。这真是一个相当不错的湖，是的。这一系列的播客节目将只是……
But so, in Rust, I tweeted something. What's this person doing? They're parking there. Go take a little walk. Go take a little gander. Yeah, we don't have time for that. We are not late, but we're're not we're not not late all right back back to rust so the whole point of this one hour including the blood cake reviews the blood reviews the restaurant reviews
说，说，说，说，哇！说，说，说，说，哇！所以，在 Rust 中，我发了一条推特。这个人正在干嘛？他们在那里停车。去散个小步。去四处溜达一下。是的，我们没时间那样做。我们并不算晚，但我们也不是……不是不晚。好吧，言归正传，回到 Rust。所以这整整一小时，包括布莱德蛋糕的评价、布莱德评价、餐厅评价，
was to get back to why rust is so amazing so someone posted on Twitter when I think I, I, I screenshotted a, uh, slide from my composition intuition talk. And I said, this might be one of my favorite slides. And it showed a couple different solutions. The one in, uh, Haskell Q maybe C plus plus, and then like BQN or APL. And someone commented, Oh, like, you know, wait until, you know you know or like or rip rust or something like that like you know rust doesn't have a good solution for this and i was like oh let me go let me go pound out the solution to this and rust and i knew immediately though i was like ah this is with strings though and i do not know rust well enough i have not mastered the string types they have like they have a lot of them, yeah, they've got like the library string. Then they've got the language string slice and, and there's a bunch of other string
都是为了回到 Rust 为什么如此 amazing。所以有人在推特上发了一条……我想我截图了我那场“组合直觉”演讲中的一张幻灯片。我说，这可能是我最喜欢的幻灯片之一。它展示了几个不同的解决方案。Haskell 中的一个，也许还有 C++ 的，然后像 BQN 或 APL。有人评论说：“哦，就像，你知道的，等着吧，你知道的，”或者类似“Rust 完了”之类的话，就好像，你知道的，Rust 没有针对这个的好的解决方案。然后我就想：“哦，让我去，让我去在 Rust 里敲出这个解决方案。”我立刻就知道，但这涉及到字符串，而且我对 Rust 还不算精通，我还没有掌握它们的字符串类型，它们有很多种字符串，是的，它们有很多。比如标准库的 string。然后它们有语言层的字符串切片（string slice），还有一堆其他的字符串
stuff. And I just, I can never know. I never know which one you're supposed to use, but I, I coded up my function in the Rust playground and, and then what happened? Then basically, uh, I did it with string slices, which is the ampersand STR. And I did that and immediately started trying to call iterate or like iter functions, the ones that implement the iterator trait. And that was a two lane road. Yeah. OK, let's make sure. And basically, you can't do that.
东西。我永远搞不懂。我永远不知道你到底应该用哪一个。但我还是在 Rust Playground 中编写了我的函数，然后发生了什么？然后基本上……我用的是字符串切片，也就是 ampersand STR（&str）。我这样做了，并立即开始尝试调用 iter 或类似 iter 的函数，即实现 Iterator trait（迭代器特征）的那些函数。那是条双车道公路。对。好的，确保一下。基本上，你不能那样做。
So I was trying to do it with a zip, a map, and like a sum, and immediately, you can't call zip on a string slice. But what does, take a guess at what, you're not going to know, so I'll just tell you. But I mean, the rest of the listeners will know what the compiler tells you. The compiler says, unfortunately, you can't call, you know, the string slice doesn't implement the iterator trait, call.cars.
所以我当时正尝试用 zip、map 和 sum 来实现，而立刻，你不能对字符串切片调用 zip。但是猜猜看，你不会知道，所以我直接告诉你。不过我的意思是，其余的听众会知道编译器会告诉你什么。编译器会说，不幸的是，你不能调用，你知道的，字符串切片没有实现 Iterator trait，请调用 .chars()。
It tells you exactly what you need to do. There's no like, hey, this might be what you want. It just knows if you're trying to call this function that requires the iterator trait and you're working with a string slice, it just goes ahead and tells you, hey, you need to go call.cars before you can call.zip, and you're good to go then. Okay. Why don't they just make calling.zip on it work? Hey, that's not the point.
它确切地告诉你需要做什么。没有什么“嘿，这可能是你想要的”。它只是知道如果你试图调用这个需要 Iterator trait 的函数，而你正在处理字符串切片，它就会直接告诉你：“嘿，在你调用 .zip 之前，你需要去调用 .chars()”，然后你就可以顺利进行了。好的。为什么他们不直接让对它调用 .zip 正常工作呢？嘿，重点不在这里。
The point... I don't know. I want an answer to my question, Connor. I'm not a Rust expert. I don't have the answer. My point here though is that like, you know, when you're starting with C++ and you do something with, you know,
重点是……我不知道。我想要我问题的答案，康纳。我不是 Rust 专家。我没有答案。不过我的重点是，当你在用 C++ 时，如果你做了一些你不是很熟悉的事情，
something you're not super familiar with, you're just going to get a mess. Whereas in Rust, you do the wrong thing and if they think they know what you're supposed to do,, you're just going to get a mess. Whereas in rest, you do the wrong thing. And if they think they know what you're supposed to do, they just tell you. And it's, I almost swore. I almost swore.
你只会得到一团糟。而在 Rust 中，如果你做错了事，如果他们认为他们知道你应该做什么，你就会得到一团糟。而在 Rust 中，如果你做错了事，如果他们认为他们知道你应该做什么，他们就会直接告诉你。这……我差点说脏话。我差点说脏话。
Kids, don't swear. This is not a family-friendly podcast. Yeah, there's a few times you swore and I had to mark it explicit. So I think our podcast is now marked as explicit. Anyways, point is... Whoa, whoa, whoa. Episode one, you said, we said that this was not a family-friendly podcast.
孩子们，不要说脏话。这不是一个家庭友好的播客。是的，有几次你说了脏话，我不得不把它标记为“有露骨内容”（explicit）。所以我想我们的播客现在被标记为 explicit 了。不管怎样，重点是……哇，哇，哇。第一集的时候，你说了，我们说过这不是一个家庭友好的播客。
You said that we could swear. I think I bleeped out your... I used to put, like, duck sounds whenever you would swear for a long time, and then I got just tired at one point. Anyways... So, now you've been marked as explicit? Yeah, I think at, like, episode, like, 120 or something. Oh, my God.
你说过我们可以说脏话。我想我有很长一段时间每当你爆粗口时都会用鸭子叫声消音，然后有一次我实在厌倦了。不管怎样……所以，现在你被标记为 explicit 了？对，我想大概在第 120 集左右。哦，天哪。
Damn. Now, do they do that... Do they do that automatically? Like, they just detect it, or...? No, so you mark your own episode as explicit, but I think once you mark one episode as explicit, the podcast in general gets marked as explicit. Well, now people can't listen to the podcast with their kids.
靠。现在，他们会自动这样做吗？就像，他们只是检测到它，还是……？不，所以你要把自己的单集标记为 explicit，但我认为一旦你把某一集标记为 explicit，整个播客通常就会被标记为 explicit。好吧，现在人们不能和他们的孩子一起听这个播客了。
I would actually be interested... You know, we joke about it, but if there is anybody who listens to the podcast with their children in the car or something, let us know. We can censor ourselves. But yeah, point is is rust is awesome the folks that spend time making the beginner experience fantastic you're doing great work i would go and open up the github repo and you know leave a smiley face but uh we're on a very windy road on the side of a mountain. Very windy road. And we're doing our best not to get in a car accident.
我其实挺感兴趣的……你知道的，我们开玩笑说，但如果有谁是在车里和孩子们一起听这个播客的，请让我们知道。我们可以自我审查。但话说回来，重点是 Rust 太棒了。那些花时间让初学者体验变得绝佳的人们，你们做得太棒了。我会去打开 GitHub 仓库，你知道的，留下一个笑脸，但是……我们在山腰上一条非常蜿蜒的路上。非常蜿蜒的路。我们在尽最大努力避免发生车祸。
Very windy, narrow road. Yep. Oh, I mean, you're a little, okay. All right. When there's a car next to me, we're going to drive a little bit off. You know, at least we're not on the outer edge. Yeah, okay. Look at this guy.
非常蜿蜒、狭窄的路。是的。哦，我的意思是，你有点……好吧。好吧。当旁边有车时，我们要稍微往外开一点。你知道，至少我们不在最外缘。是的，好吧。看看这家伙。
He's like, you know, he's in my lane. You know, I got a, I'm either going to hit him. Dude, there are not lanes on this road. There's a faded dotted line. Yeah, yeah. Sure. Anyways, that wraps our first episode of being in Slovenia. I mean, did we just wrap?
他就像是，你知道的，他在我的车道上。你知道，我得……我要么会撞到他。老兄，这条路上根本没有车道。只有一条褪色的虚线。对，对。当然。不管怎样，这标志着我们斯洛文尼亚之旅第一集的结束。我的意思是，我们这就结束了吗？
Damn. I don't actually know. Look at that mountain. Wow. And look at those mountains. Is that snow? Yeah. Wow.
靠。我其实不知道。看看那座山。哇。看看那些山。那是雪吗？是的。哇。
Damn. Well, I wish you all could see this, but this is a podcast, so not the best format for... Slovenia, 2023 road trip. Yep. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast dot com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity.
靠。好吧，我希望大家都能看到这些，但这是一个播客，所以这不是展示……的最好格式。2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行。是的。请务必查看你的播客应用或访问 ADSP the podcast dot com 上的节目简介，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及可供你留下评论、想法和问题的 GitHub 讨论区链接。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。
That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带着点点信息碎片的混乱。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。